have you ever wondered what it'd be like  to follow the path of a Witcher in the  Commonwealth well lucky for you a  Witcher gear mod for fallout 4 is now  available the mod created by Nexus mod  user rent is called gerelds prologue  gears and it includes crossbows the  white wolf starting armor and a wolf  mask the crossbows sound and reload like  a pistol but they can also fire rifle as  well as pistol rounds if you're  wondering why the mod looks so similar  to the witcher 3 developer CD Projekt  RED gave them otter permission to use  the original models and textures from  their game it's metal gear solid 5 is  more your game there is also a mod that  lets you play as characters from the  phantom pain that mod is called Metal  Gear Solid all-in-one standalone and  that was created by user akiba 91  unfortunately fallout 4 mods still  aren't available on consoles but  Bethesda promises that they're on their  way for more insane fallout 4 mods stay  tuned to gamespot